Really, let's get serious
for a second.
There was really no preparing me
for this life.
I was thrown into this
at 12 years old,
and I didn't really know what
I was getting myself into.
There's been moments
I'm really proud of,
and a lot of moments
I look back
and I'm pretty disappointed
in myself for,
but the things that I've done
really don't define who I am.
I'm a kindhearted person
who loves people,
and through it all I lost
some of my best qualities.
For that, I'm sorry.
But what I can say is I'm
looking forward to being someone
that you guys can all look at
and be proud of,
someone you can smile at
and see some of yourself in.
Someone close to me
once said,
"It's how you rise
from a fall
that truly defines you
as a man."
I'm excited
for that challenge,
and I want to say
thank you so much
for taking this journey
with me,
and I'm excited for you
to see what's next.
Thank you, God,
for your grace
and for never
giving up on me.
[cheers and applause]
But one more thing.
One more thing before I go.
There's someone in my life who
I owe a special apology to.
I'm talking about someone
who I really loved
and lost because
I screwed it all up,
but thankfully
that special someone,
the love of my life,
is here tonight.
I just want that second chance,
so if you could come on out.
This is your monkey.
I missed you, buddy.
Want to go to the zoo?
I'm just kidding.
Thank you so much
and good night.